if you've lost your job or you're about
to you're in a very very unstable
situation with your income not generally
afraid of the Cova cut downs the
coronavirus shut downs but you really
are about to lose a job or have lost a
job or you're furloughed okay to buy
food first lights and water second pay
your mortgage or you're in third do Pete
keep gas in your car do look for an
interim job with one of the grocery
chains or the delivery folks all the
pizza places are hiring you can make
some money to keep your household
running for a period of time until that
job you had comes back or you get a new
one
yeah just like if you just walked in in
an on coronavirus situation they said
we're doing layoffs you wouldn't just go
home and sit and cry you might for a
minute but then you get up and you get
after it yes sir you got a hustle and
grind right and so you do that don't
cash out your 401k unless it's to avoid
a bankruptcy or foreclosure and there's
no way you're in a bankruptcy or a
foreclosure today because of the
coronavirus no way you are already there
and the coronavirus pushed you over the
edge maybe all right but the coronavirus
shut down and associated income losses
are not old enough to have caused a
bankruptcy or foreclosure a foreclosure
folks take six months in almost every
state and usually longer and so if
you've missed
April's payment you are not in
foreclosure you're just late that's it
calm down do not cash out your 401k now
let's take another group of people and
say you are oh ok your income is stable
but you're just generally worried about
the whole coronavirus thing well welcome
the human race right right but and so
like I don't know
Papo works at UPS and Mama's a teacher
yeah okay those are two stable income
stable they're not you know I got an
issue though that deliveries are going
on
and the teacher salaries even though
they're at home are going on yeah and
they're really not in jeopardy they're
not about to be furloughed they're not
they're not about to do a bunch of
massive layoffs those are two stable
incomes your federal employee you're a
postal worker you're a health care
worker you ain't going nowhere nowhere
okay so those are stable incomes now
what are some do's and don'ts there so
do pay your bills on time yes all of
them yes do go ahead and continue to
baby steps whatever baby cept you're on
if you're getting out of debt do go
ahead and continue getting out of debt
yes don't take advantage of some of
these forbearance plans delay your
utility bills do not do that and that's
very very very frustrating Dave I'm
going to pay my bill my mortgage payment
the other day and I'll just read up on a
forbearance plan they're offering and
here's why I say do not do it even if
you are a little scared continue paying
bills like we said because at the end of
your forbearance plan if it's three
months all of it comes due at one time
including that month you look up the
word forbearance yes in the dictionary
or that google it for those of you don't
know what a dictionary is but it does
not mean forgiveness yep it means
patience yes if I have forbearance with
you it means I have patience with you a
forbear with you and I give I give you
time that's all it means and so if you
don't pay your payment this month guess
what has you still got to pay it yeah
patients are gonna make up by this year
yes it's gonna come back so delaying it
just to say I delayed it unless you
can't pay it but it's one of the first
three things you pay and you should be
taking a job doing something so do not
get involved in all these forbearance
programs if there's any way you can
avoid it because it's gonna catch up
with you later and do not if you're
entrepreneur business owner Dave you
could talk more into this because that's
what you are do not take advantage of
these government loans that they're
calling government grants that they're
not a grant yeah they're not a grant it
is a loan with forgiveness provisions
and you read the details of the law like
I've done in the last 24 hours it'll
scare the pee widen out of you so yeah
and you listen if you don't maintain
employee
exactly like it was and they're gonna be
looking at every little thing then
you're gonna get bit later yeah avoid
this now I'll tell you there is
something you do want to do if you're a
small business they are allowing the
portion of the payroll tax that I have
to pay as the employer to not get paid
this whole year ooh
and it had and then it is paid
systematically or not over the next two
years it's delayed it's not forgiven
it's put off but it's delayed and if
that will help you and you know that's a
lot of money here with a thousand people
working on this team so we will
definitely be not paying that payroll
tax under this provision knowing that we
have to pay it next year and the next
year you make it up over the next two
years but through the end of the year
that's a lot of cash flow that will help
make sure that our employees stay
employed that we don't have to furlough
or lay somebody off by protecting that
cat that monthly cash flow do that one
yes so do not borrow money yes from the
SBA yes churches do not borrow money
from the SBA you've the borrower is
slave to the lender when the government
comes in and after this is over and some
of these people that don't agree with
your biblical viewpoint of life are
going to come in and start telling you
you have to do this in order to get
forgiveness the Treasury Department is
sitting the regulations in place and
they take direction from Congress and
from the you and from the president and
depending on who's in the White House
after November that could get really
messy for some of you people in the
church world in particular and you do
not want to get involved in all of a
sudden you don't do something the way
they think and according to political
correctness and you think that the Bible
says opposite of that and now you're
gonna find out the borrower is slave to
the lender do not take this money it is
not free money and Dave here's another
one do not do cash advances do not do
payday lender place drove past a place
yesterday i Seward and I was so upset
and my ig followers knew it
I got on there and I I was trying to be
respectful to the company cuz I'm gonna
get in trouble why well because you're
my boss and I don't want you calling me
I think you ought to take them down you
know but I mean I've seen 13 cars out
there at this particular payday lender
place and I was frustrating for jobs do
not borrow money at 800 percent Interest
don't do it don't and that's what the
payday lender charges they're scum and
they're gonna take advantage of you stay
off of that lot unless you're sweeping
the lot and they're paying you to sweep
it don't even go in their driveway yes
do not do that stuff do not cash out
your 401k because you're afraid do not
cash out your mutual funds because
you're afraid this time next year you
will be kicking yourself going ah yeah I
jumped off a rollercoaster right in the
middle of the ride no wonder both my
legs got broke I mean my god don't do
this don't take out a lot of credit on
your home don't be borrowing money yeah
it's this mess covered don't be
borrowing money on credit cards to cover
this mess the number of times Anthony
doing crisis counseling over these 30
years that I've sat down with somebody
they go well I lost my job last fall and
that's how I got this forty five
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
I'm like wait a minute how long were you
out of work two months what did you make
before you got laid off sixty thousand
dollars that's five thousand dollars a
month
that's not forty five thousand and two
months that's ten thousand what's the
other thirty five thousand oh we bought
some other stuff but we justified it and
rationalized it being called it
unemployment debt and all it was was
stupid yeah because I was stressed out
freaked out and I went to the mall to
feel better I went to the car lot to
feel better and bought a bass boat to
feel better God don't do this stuff this
is the time to be wise and calm and
deliberate and very careful steps on
these slippery rocks you're gonna fall
and bust your butt in the creek and be
wet very careful steps do not cash out
your investments do not delay payments
on these loans these student loans you
got I got free interest okay I hear
people saying delay the payment you're
just you're jumping all over them on
them
jumping all over them if you still got
the income and stuff coming in no go
after the payments because now you can
put more payment more money towards to
principle ya might note no interest on
my student loan for six months so that
doesn't mean me you stay in debt six
more months oh it means if you have a
steady income you attack that much
harder come on now if you're doing the
four walls cool yes set it aside we're
not worried about Sallie Mae she can
star feed your kids yeah but but if you
are got a steady income bust that thing
man use this opportunity to push through
don't be skipping payments unless you
have to to eat that's it with the Dave
Ramsey show Ramsey personality dr. D dr.
John Bologna PhD in counseling for those
of you that are not you bet yet been
introduced to him talking a lot today
about anxiety about fear and taking your
financial questions your questions about
how to deal with some of those things
where maybe where people are mean to you
or inappropriate to you how do you react
how do you set boundaries in those
situations and dr. you'll be with us
answering your questions so what are
some of the things that people can do
because like our team went home last
week so there's nobody in our building
right now except a handful of a skeleton
crew to get this radio show going in
case people didn't know we got about a
thousand people in the building doing
all kinds of other things have nothing
to do with radio and they're all working
from home this week and next week and
what car things people can do in those
situations too because that break-in
routine can add to fear can wipe you out
right it's there's this part of our
brain that is so I guess trick to
believe that familiarity is safety right
anytime you get plugged into something
and it's new every alarm system goes off
right so it's just about setting a new
routine set a new mapping out your day
if you're if you're married if you got
kids if you're by yourself set a plan
set a plan for the day so like if you
have a like almost a daily agenda and
you follow that even though it's new
because it was a plan at lower stress
that's right and it'll take a couple of
days expect your kids to push on you and
find out how strong those boundaries are
expect your co-workers and your your
significant others to lean on you a
little bit see how firm your that
boundaries gonna be but absolutely set
up a plan and over a couple of days
yeah it's becoming your new normal right
now homeschooling is now a way of life I
mean for a lot of people and is I love
the post I saw this week that lady set
up homeschooling uh we just started it
it's going well so far two of the
students have been expelled for fighting
and the teacher got fired for drinking
yeah the teacher got fired for drinking
so it's just it's bad but yeah I mean
it's a lot of people are experiencing
some new stuff during this two weeks
they're also experiencing lot job loss
right if you're in the hospitality world
anywhere you're probably at home that's
right
airline restaurants for sure lots of
hotels you're at home and you don't even
know if you're going back in a lot of
cases nice carry and that can be really
really scary how do you manage through
the stress of I can talk about how to
handle the money through the
unemployment side but how do you manage
through the stress of that I think
there's a couple of things you can do I
think the first thing is to not curl up
in a ball right because that's that's
some of our default position and like
you said earlier either curl up in a
ball or don't start being angry at
people I think the most important thing
you never want is to get connected to
folks and make sure that when you're
staying at home that you're still
facetiming with people you haven't
talked to still call them people you
haven't talked to you showing gratitude
to folks whether it's to yourself or
whether it's to your neighbors are
important to health care workers
delivery drivers and then honoring your
body making sure you are sleeping and
exercising and not just in the media
sphere right not just scrolling all day
if you're scrolling through a bag of
chocolate chip cookies and through every
possible negative media account by the
end of the day you are gonna be
measuring you were just spinning that
anxiety spin cycle faster and faster and
faster that's crazy cycles going on high
speed that's right that's right yeah and
you're gonna make yourself nuts that's
right get outside and just go walk yeah
that's right get outside and go walk
yeah and and there are places that are
hiring I mean it may not be the great
jobs it may not be perfect jobs that may
be tied over jobs right sometimes just
doing something do something is better
than nothing almost always it does
relieve there's some sense of I have
control of my destiny that's right even
though you we never have a hundred
percent control of our destiny we do
control the controllables and you need
to control those things and so I saw
George Camel one of our guys post that
these people are hiring right
Aldi Amazon posted I saw a letter from
their CEO they're hiring a hundred
thousand people Wow
Amazon's going bananas Costco Dollar
General Dollar Tree Domino's instacart
Jets Pizza
Kroger Microsoft Pepsi Post mates Publix
slack Target Trader Joe's UPS uber eats
Walmart Whole Foods zoom they're all
hiring that's right and so if you were
waiting tables two weeks ago you may be
working there and who knows you might
even accidentally find a new career
that's right I guess that's a Kim
Coleman show that's right and something
as similar as as it means simple as my
son and I were going for a walk the
other day and we just got a trash sack
and some little rubber gloves we had
from hunting season and we just picked
up trash in the neighborhood I can't
tell you Dave how many people stopped us
just said thank you hey can we join you
hey we're gonna go home and grab it was
just a matter of doing something we got
to walk we got some sunshine and we got
some together time me and him we stayed
appropriately distant from everybody but
then we also got to help the
neighborhood to something small
something little but I got to feel like
I wasn't just trapped in my house you
know unable to do anything right well
it's hard to have a pity party if you're
helping someone else every time every
[ __ ] is heart because a pity parties are
fairly low attended you see a party one
that's right that's right so I mean if
you find an elderly person and you can
that's locked in and you can find out
they need their shut-in I mean they need
to stay in because they're high you may
make a grocery store run for him my
buddy Kevin texted this morning he said
this is a great opportunity for
Millennials they've got a bad rap
instead of making tick tock workout
videos they could call the local Meals
on Wheels and see how they can get
involved there or find other charitable
organizations that are usually usually
rounded up by older folks in our
communities who are now having to stay
inside me what a cool moment to your
rise to the occasion and go help your
communities make an Instagram photos man
let's get out there yeah well I mean you
know there's careful because you have
Instagram and so do i but but um yeah
it's not it's not time for selfies
that's there you go this is time for
other E's or whatever you call that
right well start a whole new phrase here
but I
is something that does happen in the
brain chemistry when you're giving
rather than brooding that's right that
that helps you get through the anxiety
and we get to choose which thoughts we
ruminate on right or which ones that
we're gonna worship and so when that
negative thought that fear thought comes
in you have a choice and that is your
right I'm going to Google it I'm gonna
go down the rabbit hole of anxiety I'm
going the the rabbit hole of pessimism
or we can say not today
I'm going for a walk I'm gonna grab my
kid and we're gonna head outside or I'm
gonna go I'm gonna tell my wife great
job well what happens is inevitably
there's a real problem I mean you got to
pay the light bill
that's exactly you've got no money you
got to put food on the table and you got
no job that's right there's a real
problem but what inevitably I do and I
think it's human nature is is that we
project that problem to its possible
worst scenario a month and a half from
now that's right and you can project in
your mind the nation's economy or the
nation's carnivore carnal virus curve
right the curve cut helped me with the
curve but um you know but you can
project the worry and it just becomes
debilitating stress when you project it
out into the future that's right and
there's plenty of people who are trying
to sell that to us as well right it's
like a full-time job well and and you
know in some cases they're just afraid
that's right they're their friends and
family and they're there saying if you
know if you don't do this
although society is going to die what
kind of irresponsible this is where
people are getting mean right because
they're afraid right and it's scary from
a macro perspective what a politician a
person in government even the news media
can pull off if you can get enough
people afraid at the same time in a
while this is how dictators come to
power is in situations where people
become cheap because of fear the fear
that's right they huddle in the corner
and do everything they're told and so
I'm afraid I'm a little bit more of a
rebel than that so I'm a little bit
harder to mandate my thinking but you
have to back up and put critical
thinking skills and go okay is the cure
the problem has it reached the point
that the cure is worse than the virus
has it reached the point that the
permanent damage to families futures has
superseded their health and for me I
tend to go macro like you say I tend to
get two years five years down the road
and think of all these what-ifs and what
I have to always do is draw myself back
and say I actually don't know the answer
when I can't control it that's right
control is what I can control which is
me right now and I have to be concerned
about the families that work on my team
and are they going to be able to pay
their bills because I acted responsibly
and kept this place running right or
versus am i putting their health at risk
that's exactly right and that's a
leaders position it's sort of have to
make those decisions and you know in a
family you have to do the same thing and
as an individual you have to do the same
thing but no one makes good decisions
when they're panicked or drunk laughs or
says my favorite quote of the year and
I'm gonna use it a lot he sent me an
email last night it matter if I quoting
it again
so dr. John Delaney with us this hour
half hour next hour as we talk about
money and we talk about what's going on
out there and your feelings about it I
got a coach got a counselor right here
beside me they give us our question of
the day from Nancy in New York Dave you
often refer to having three to six
months of expenses but what do you
include for example as a homeowner do I
include my school and property taxes
thank you
what does it take to operate your
household a month over the scope coat
over the scope of a year yes that would
include paying your taxes yes that would
include operating your household for a
year and divide that by 12 and you've
got your annual I mean you got your
monthly and then multiply that by the
three or six right now everybody's kind
of thinking six there's a lot of a lot
of people tempting me on social media to
say I told you so but I'm not going to
do that if you're hurting and you don't
have your emergency fund
I understand you know the beauty of a
moment in time like this John is that I
remember when my grandpa was alive one
of my favorite men to ever live
grandpa Ramsey he was a good man
and taught me to drive a tractor taught
me how to pull a rusty nail out of a
board and you can't hear me again you
can now good okay pull a rusty nail out
of a board and straighten it out you
know
old nail and put it in a coffee can yeah
and his entire habit pattern in 1970 was
affected by 1929 that's right
and it made him frugal the Great
Depression made him frugal
he's probably naturally for a goal or
scotch-irish so we probably naturally
frugal people in our DNA or in our
environment or whatever but these times
set new boundaries in your life and
sometimes as a personal crisis but when
you go through a national thing that you
like your wake-up call and you go never
again will I be caught without an
emergency fine because my stress level
goes way down when I have six months of
cash in the bank and we're facing a
one-month crisis it changes everything
people reset their brains don't they and
it beautiful and when you have a crisis
your brain remembers I don't ever want
that to happen again yeah
it's debilitating in one sense no sense
it's a permanent change and it's free if
you can support a transformation that's
right that's right it can free you and
you can say never again there's my never
again moment I'm never going to be
caught off guard by it by a virus I
can't even see right an enemy I can't
even see and I'm gonna make changes
today that make sure this never happens
again yeah I went to a personal one when
I went bankrupt and then lost everything
I said never again that's right am I
gonna be in a position never again will
I miss a tithe check never again will I
be without an emergency fund never been
again will I be without cash never again
will I be in debt where someone's takes
something when something moves it's
beyond my control and that's what
happened to me it was beyond my control
but what wasn't beyond my control was
being in debt being in debt was in my
control yeah and so I don't never put my
made myself susceptible to a national
calamity much less a personal calamity
again in those areas that's right now
I'm susceptible in other ways I can't
you can't everyone's susceptible
something you can
trol the controllables and you say never
again that's right and I've done the
same thing with I'm never gonna say that
to my wife again yeah and I'm never
gonna ruminate on the negative what
could be easy get right and you said all
those never again and then you start
creating patterns and opportunities for
yourself and Phil's around you that that
never happens again yeah and then when
later on when you looks like someone
says well everybody else goes in debt
everybody else gets a credit card
everyone else has a car payment everyone
else that does not save money because
everyone knows that the economy's okay
everyone knows that you're gonna be okay
everyone everyone everyone everyone and
I just look at them and what my old
pastors should say a man with an
experience is not at the mercy of a man
with an opinion some of you were having
that experience right now I'm really
sorry you're hurting and I'm sorry
you're scared but the good news is and
all that manure stuff will grow that's
right and a friend of mine he's a
rancher in West Texas and we were he
sent me an article once about parents
and Great Britain in the UK giving their
kids iPads and they're two years old and
they said I didn't want my kid to be the
only one and so him and I started saying
that back and forth just be the only one
and if you find yourself thinking well
everyone else has credit cards and
that's what the way that normal I'm
gonna be the only one right if everyone
else treats their wife this way I'm
gonna be the only one who doesn't do
that right and suddenly or excuse me
over a period of time people will start
to say why are you calming this when
things are going bananas why does what
are you and your wife have such a great
marriage why do your kids act this way
in restaurants when mind oh and suddenly
you realize oh because you're the only
one that acts like that right and then
people around you start to change the
way they live too my kid was enraged by
screens there you go and my bank
accounts not empty that's right because
I'm Yolo that's you know it's just Dave
Ramsey's ridiculous day you know the
stuff we teach is antiquated it doesn't
make sense in the real world and then
not as an i-told-you-so but just as just
to say guys the stuff we teach works in
good times and the stuff we teach works
in bad times that's because it's what's
known as the truth that's right
and fear tells you what you really
believe right like I'm scared of I'm
scared of not having enough or I'm
kind person I'm a giving person I'm a
joyful person I follow all the rules now
you can find out you've been talking
about Davis we can find out right now
when you're scared what do you really
believe who are you are you still kind
are you still tithing are you still
giving and you're still joyful you get
to find out right now you're s test
every that's right your character your
stress test your stupid stupid comes up
lacking that's right and what Buffett
said when the tide goes out you can tell
who's skinny-dipping that's exactly
right that's it that's what you're
facing so so yes you include your
property taxes and your stuff in your
emergency fund and yes having a rainy
day fund is good regardless of what type
of rain comes and it's hard to predict
all the different types of rain that can
come all right Lee is with us in South
Carolina highly welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys good afternoon my
question is what should we be investing
right now in this downturn well I mean
that the stock market is down for one
thing obviously and so continuing to
fund your 401 K with good mutual funds
is what I'm doing and I'm in the middle
of building a building over here next
door for the next piece of growth for
Ramsey solutions so I don't have a bunch
of spare cash to throw in the mutual
funds while the mother on sale right now
or I would have but I am continuing my
steady 401 K Rachel and once them you
know they're doing their 401 K so that's
down other things you can look around it
you know if there are things that you
are normally purchasing that are down
real estate is not down right now
interest rates are down on mortgages and
so refinancing is a good time right now
but as far as straight-up investing the
biggest thing it's on sale right now is
the stock market yeah and I've heard a
lot of people you know because
everything is quote-unquote on sale
they're trying to get in there and like
do different things and all of that but
we're still pretty boring even in a
downturn with the market of just doing
mutual funds I mean so a lobby where I
say no is there a single stock is there
something I should kind of dip in and go
around we're pretty simple and just like
hey it's mutual funds so you're still
going to get a great deal on that but
at the end of the day being able to
diversify your risk and not going after
these single sucks but I've seen a lot
of people in talks of that they're
trying to like pin the system do all
these like kind of different things
because it's down but don't take the
common you know I mean use the common
sense approach of mutual funds all the
way diversify that risk you know that's
a good point because what happens is
people lose money I in stuff like
investing in mutual funds or investing
the stock market in in general they lose
money when they're fearful and they pull
it the wrong time they also can lose
money when they're greedy yeah and
they're saying you know I'm yes you know
and it's like that kind of a thing and
you're not doing that Austin that's not
your thing Emily I'm sorry that's not
what you're suggesting you're just
asking knowledge questions yeah the
timing is good what can we do
well good mutual funds but what you're
suggesting right choice I'm gonna try
something super risky right now because
I'm so excited that everything's on sale
that's a kind of agreed right that's
more than what just wise steady
investing and so be aware of that that
greedy thing there is a famous Warren
Buffett saying and he doesn't mean
greedy like a lack of virtue type greedy
but he always says being greedy greedy
when others are fearful and fearful when
others are greedy and he doesn't mean be
fearful sucking their thumb in the
corner or being greedy like I'm
something from a movie but his point is
be investing when people are not
investing and when they're not investing
maybe you know or when they are
investing maybe you shouldn't be that
kind of thing he's always once he's a
contrarian yeah the opposite of what's
going on but just beware that if you get
desperate you get stupid and if you get
greedy you get stupid so Rachel's point
is don't dive off into some weird thing
or some single stock or some you can get
scammed with this kind of stuff going on
right now that you know the
opportunities to jump in right now and
then show the coronaviruses what suit
this is awesome you know and know that
that right there is it good you start
feeling that kind of emotion that's not
what he's saying but your warning
against that so yeah I think just
continuing to do your 401k investing and
if you have some extra money that you
want leave alone ten years yeah it's a
great time the more stock markets on
sale when I was a kid there used to have
blue lights at Kmart when there's a sale
and you'd run over to where the blue
light wasn't buy whatever it was on sale
and so that's what's happening on the
stock market right now there's a blue
light on so we're taking questions a lot
of you are facing some fear out there
you're afraid of the economy the harm to
the economy brought on by what is
perceived to be the cure not the cure
but the way to limit the pandemic is
everyone stay at home and shut down all
the businesses which shuts down people's
income which shuts down their lives and
so their lives are being harmed more by
the cure the average person in America
than by the actual virus and and some of
you are very very afraid we've been
urging people to remain calm no one
makes good decisions when they're drunk
or when they're panicked and some of you
are both and you some of you're being
really mean to other people because
you're afraid and you need to check
yourself this is a time that you need to
grow up or the garden if you're 54 and
and you know I think one of the things
I've seen that has caused people to be
the meanest
particularly when it's directed at
public figures including myself is when
I don't know what this is John in the
human psyche you can help me with this I
there's a level of arrogance mmm
aristocracy sense entitlement sense that
tells you that it's not only your job to
manage your space but you're supposed to
tell everyone else what to do hmm
so we used to doing as kids we say nunya
right none your business all right but
mind your own business but people can't
do that anymore they're really good
minding everyone else's business but you
got a full-time job just taking care of
your house right now you have more than
a full-time job you get more than a
full-time job taking care of your own
head right now I think we talked about
fierce calls and people to be unkind I
also think insecurity is - because
there's this myth that we all should
know what we're supposed to do all the
time especially husbands and dads across
the country moms and wives across the
country I'm supposed to know what to do
and you get this moment I don't know
what to do and then the best way I can
solve that sometimes it's did yell at
somebody else and tell them old you're
doing yours wrong right like we have
this hierarchy if as long as I'm not as
bad as my neighbor is that I'm okay yeah
and that goes directly in opposition to
just being kind my critical thinking
path that I don't know where it came
from
it may be just my hillbilly rebellion
self but um its contrarian and so as
soon as someone says this is the way it
is I immediately think oh it's not
that's exactly how I am - that's right
yeah no it's not it's like and you know
the CDC says this and I'm like my cousin
works at the CDC you know that proves it
right there you know I mean it's like so
what if what if we're in the new
rebellion is kindness yeah or the new
rebellion is tipping obnoxiously right
yeah or delivering groceries or somebody
shut in that's exactly right
as you said you walk down the street
with a garbage bag in rubber gloves with
your son picking up trash just to get
out of house get some vitamin D but
that's exactly you know that's right and
how's that for a new rebellion right
yeah a whole different kind of a
kindness rebellion but I'm just my point
is is that my first inclination is to be
a sheepdog as to the Sheep mmm I
immediately challenge authority whatever
it is and you know you know my wife is
pregnant with our first child 35 years
ago and the OB says such a section I
went I don't think so oh man and she
said you're so bad about that you're not
a doctor I said yeah I know but you're
gonna have to prove that I don't I just
take it just because you got a white
coat and a stethoscope does not mean I'm
gonna believe you you got to make your
case dude hmm and you know I made this
case and I went along but and
but but it's not it was not you know I'm
not gonna just automatically fall in
line that's right that's my nature and
so just because the president says
something the governor says something
for God's sakes the mayor says something
that's proof right there that I'm just
not going along you know I'm not
necessarily gonna think the way they
think I have other responsibilities I
have critical thinking skills that are
different and I have you know I have to
think for myself and you got to think
for yourself that's right in this and so
you know I've got a friend who's
recovering from cancer and has been
through chemo and he's thinking for
himself which he's staying at home it's
a really good idea yeah that's right
yeah and not being you know out there
not connecting to anybody because he's
in a weakened state he's in a high-risk
category with this thing so answering
your questions about those subjects
about fear anxiety about money about
life on the planet right now in this
weird and wacky time we love you but we
love ourselves to the point you're not
allowed to be mean and so I'm not gonna
fight with you you're just wrong you
need to be kind I say just need to calm
your little butt down and be kind we
have a new ramsey personality dr.
jeong's Aloni and you're gonna be
hearing through a whole lot more
one of his two PhDs is in counseling and
so we thought it would be good for John
to coach some of you guys on how to talk
to yourself about the anxiety the fear
that's out there how to talk to your
family about it you might be in a
leadership role we were talking about it
off air during the break some stuff you
know some stuff I'm having to do as the
leader in this organization right now
and you know how to talk to others
yourself others if you want to if you
want to deal with that the phone number
here if you've got questions for dr. D
this is your time the phone numbers
triple eight eight two five five two two
five triple eight eight two five five
two two five so John talk about anxiety
versus fear we were talking about the
other day and I loved your take on it
so anxiety is just an alarm system right
it's just the fire alarm that could go
off at any moment when it smells smoke
right and you often hear about folks
with an anxiety disorder that that just
means the alarms busted right and we've
all been in the building when the fire
alarms going off and you can't you can't
check your email and they say they don't
leave the building don't leave the
building but the fire alarms are going
off your brains fried there you go from
the hearing fear is that's something
you're experiencing right now the
building you look out the window and you
see flames that's that's fear that's for
real right and so I think what we're
seeing across the country is fear is
real and if you're not scared if you're
not scared on that you think people
overreact in you're not scared that
we're all gonna die from this virus
you're not scared about fill in the
blank
you're not scared that you have ten kids
at your house now that we're supposed to
be in school right then I think
something's wrong with you right yeah
should be feeling something you should
feel some angst there you go some level
of fear so good fear is there and then
you know that keeps you from touching a
hot stove it causes you to analyze and
use your critical thinking skills and
really lean into a situation absolutely
which is what we're dealing with right
now you might have a financial situation
you might have a career mess right now
you might have a health mess
right now but and so fear in those
situations are smart over correcting
with fear what I've been calling
hysteria and it might not be clinically
the correct term but I'm calling it
hysteria which is people they're just
afraid they're they're in panic mode the
difference in fear and panic talk about
that panic is the response right it's
screaming and yelling and running out
the door and the only thing that you're
gonna do when you scream and yell and or
not the doors trip your neighbor knock
over their lighter so they fit the
building off it just panic solves
nothing
it solves nothing and it takes a
situation and compounds it makes it
worse
yeah everybody my the guy who trained me
in crisis counseling dr. Andy Young used
to always tell us before we went into a
situation calm is contagious
you walk into a situation and you're
running and screaming you just take
everybody else's temperature up with you
walk in assess the situation slow down
bring the room down and then you can
make good decisions
I had a almost twenty two years old I
was working for a guy we were building
custom homes and he used that technique
in a little different way if we had a
customer that was irate and sat down the
office the louder they got the quieter
he got that's right the louder they got
the more he lowered the octave in his
voice of intentionally just because his
lectures organized real quiet and calm
and it just it what it does it just
sucks the drama out of the air my dad
was a hostage negotiator he used to
drive me crazy when he did that to me as
a kid right I'd come in all freaked out
and he would just kind of bring it down
bring it down that's right yeah a volume
down and the octave down and the pulse
rate down and then because no one makes
good decisions with their panic that's
right
and when were when we experience fear
naturally its wired into us we starts
again in the environment for fear and
now we're in a world where there is no
shortage of people trying to sell us
fear and so it's coming on our phones
it's beeping on a wrist it's on our TVs
it's on it's on every it's everywhere
and it really contagious it's insane
clinically so right and so it's how do
you turn the noise off how do you turn
it down bring it down a notch and I
think some of the times what happens is
and we when I was talking to our team
yesterday I was describing to them the
idea that that the physiological
response to fear and anger is pretty
close the same things happen to your
body in both cases you know you have the
same your eyes dilate you have a protein
endorphin release and adrenaline release
your heart rate changes you know so fear
and anger feel hmm a lot of like they
are cousins aren't they I think
physiologically you can say that that's
fair yeah and then just how we choose to
name it in those situations whether
you're what's your default mechanism is
my default is anger
my wife's default is fear I've got a
good friend whose default his fear and
that doesn't mean anything it doesn't
mean you're a fearful person or an angry
person it just means that that's that's
how you interpret a situation how you
choose to go at it if you don't stop and
breathe and wisdom is knowing what my
default setting is catching myself
before I do something and surrounded
myself with smart people who know that's
my default setting right I've got a
group of guys in my life who know I'm
about to they'll roll their eyes and say
hasta Loney right they know they know
where I'm about to head with something
and they're there to kind of rein me
back in yeah the phone number if you
want to talk to dr. Dee about these
things that are going on in the
marketplace triple 8 8 to 5 5 to 2 5
triple 8 8 to 5 5 to 25 one of you is
going to be the first call he ever takes
in his radio career you have that
opportunity right now that's like
winning the sweepstakes right there I'm
gonna yeah in that I don't know what
that wins yeah so in most situations in
my experience when the threat is real
people rise up and in situations like
this where the the fear has spread to a
real threat to the point that the
reaction does not match the threat
mm-hmm and you know from the times
you've done where you've been in crisis
counseling with folks you've been in
situations like that do you see that
people have a tendency just the
human-animal has a tendency to do that I
think you just said it best it's you
kind of devolve to your internal
instincts right which is to either say
all the information we're getting stupid
or all the information we're getting is
the right thing or I'm gonna start
buying toilet paper as they were having
a mass diarrhea epidemic right I mean
it's this people are responding
irrationally
right absolutely dysentery is not one of
the symptoms not one of ours not one of
the things the things it's not what's
causing it but I have no idea but and
water it being in the water system is
not one of the methods that a couple of
weeks ago when it started sell out of
water and get the bottle it's kind of
hose I don't I just don't get it
what are you doing if there was a run on
meat or vegetables I'd met I could go
with that or a run on vitamin C water
water
I got a sink man I got a bathtub I mean
work yeah as if the public water supply
was going to get tainted who knows
what games going through people's minds
nothing nothing nothing good yeah
nothing thoughtful I guess so how do you
um talk to your teen right now your
college student that has been infected
by this fear and help them have the
wisdom to address the actual threat
without an overreaction
I'll default back to another thing we
learned in crisis counseling which is
fax your friends be honest be
straightforward be direct which is we've
never experienced this before some
people are saying this some people are
saying this some people are telling us
to do this and in this house here's how
we're gonna handle it right and be
pretty clear I think having a plan for
the next couple of weeks on here's what
our days are gonna look like here's how
hard we're gonna interact with each
other here's how we're gonna honor one
another here's how we're gonna limit our
screen time in the house I think there's
all kinds of things we can do but you
got to be intentional same as you would
start in a business as same as you would
trying to have a great marriage you got
to be intentional Chris are we gonna be
okay
absolutely Dave we're going to be okay
we have to calm down all the way around
and quit watching so much crazy stuff on
media oh my gosh ah it is scary the way
people are acting and I think that's
more scary than the actual facts I agree
and it has been for several weeks the
Osteria
which is panic out of control is not
your friend
yeah fat as John Delaney says fax or
your friend yes I like that and um you
know when you're in a crisis
and we obviously have a health crisis in
America we obviously have a
corresponding financial crisis mm-hmm
and and so you know bad processes bad
principles that have been in either one
of those areas and or either one of
those areas of your life are starting to
reveal themselves if you had a health
weakness of financial weakness mm-hmm it
was okay when everything was okay right
but now it's being exposed and when you
stress test stupid it comes up looking
pretty stupid stupid doesn't stress test
well and you know we get ready to do it
launch a website around here we always
stress tests if they load test it right
to put a load on it if it can carry the
load before we turn it open to the
public and this is being you know some
of you your financial your best
financial ideas you know like it's
really hard right now to be really
comfortable based on your airline miles
yeah oh I agree
virtually disposed yeah
so let's see those airline miles you
were trying to collect and we're it's
kind of that dr. Phil moment how's that
working for you now so you know and so
you know what some of the things that
people believed about money are now
officially challenged and that is the
good news of the bad news the hard times
expose this stuff and make you say never
again sometimes you go through a
personal great depression and sometimes
the nation goes through an actual stress
time and in 2008 a bunch of people
learned their lesson yes and I learned
my lesson went broke because I was
stupid and my stupid ideas got
stress-testing I got my face beat in and
I was in my 20s and I got the
opportunity to start again with the
knowledge that that experience gave me
and some of you right now I'm not gonna
tell you I told you so but this is your
wake-up call you're going to have the
opportunity to start again with the
knowledge that this mess has given you I
completely agree Dave and we're gonna
have
we're having right now I'm doing
Instagram live each day from 11:00 11:30
we've got I'm seeing more about an
awakening for people where they go you
know they're either in two camps thank
goodness
they've for your message and I've got an
emergency fund or I was on my way or I
should have listened sooner and of those
three I keep telling people you've got
an opportunity to make this now this
information become knowledge and wisdom
when you apply it in your life but what
we have to do is now realize more than
ever that we cannot wait on the
government days to save the day
I know they're talking about all the
little stimulus packages and I tell
people you know it's gonna help but it's
not gonna continue well it's not gonna
help but it's a little bit like peeing
on horse fire I mean it's a bit of a
joke I mean it's gonna help but it's you
know if $1,000 saves your life well you
didn't have a life that's true and so
your financial life you know I mean
that's just absurd
if payroll taxes being removed from a
business saves it it probably ain't
gonna make it anyway if you were that
close to the edge anyway so it's more
political hogwash than it is anything
makes everybody feel better and make
some markets feel better and I'm not if
they want to do it it's okay
but for giving $10,000 of your student
loan debt doesn't fix your financial
clock you are gonna fix your financial
problem and that message is not changed
around here the people that have debt
and no savings they're finding out that
this idea that there's good debt is
bogus because this is when their stupid
ideas stress-test ago every time there's
debt it accelerates the volatility in
your life and in the nation's life
because the consumer is so leveraged and
the consumer has no savings and so you
know one two-week period of time with no
pay and you're just completely
devastated right and so what happened to
me because I was stupid was I had that
same thing happened only wasn't a
two-week period of time I made $200,000
one year in my 20s the next year I made
$6,000 in the process of losing
everything we owned and I discovered I
this leverage I borrowed
money wasn't my friend was only my
friend when everything went perfect and
never does everything go perfect
and not having any cash was a dumb idea
not having granite rimmel's rainy day
fund it's gonna rain dummy that's what
that's what I kept saying to myself and
so I changed that and thank God I did
all those years ago and I've talked a
few of you out there if you million of
you out there into doing that and hmm
and so you're sitting there right now
kind of feeling like wow this stuff
works I'm really glad that all these
people that made fun of me my broke
friends when they were making fun of me
for cutting up my credit cards because I
didn't get the airline miles but rough
line on it right now yeah and you're
supposed to be in your home suckin your
thumb you're not supposed to be flying
on an airplane and so no trouble social
distancing on them though because
nobody's on them but you know the but
you see the thing I mean it's that the
the the everything is is exponentially
more volatile in our economy and in our
personal homes the more debt we have and
in other words debt equals risk now this
is not something that you have not said
and I have not said that's exactly right
we have been saying this and now we're
observing it like a bunch of lab rats
well and Dave and and people are feeling
it and hearing it on another level now
yeah
and it's crazy I've heard you say this
before that you have to get to your
uncle point you know and I have uncle's
in them where they would get me in holds
and get me in that point where I would
say I'm big on it was a little bit you
as a little girl hello Korean but
unfortunately this is what requires us
to wake up and really and truly not just
talk about change but be about change in
our lives and I'm talking to people that
will say Chris this has never happened
to me again yeah this fear whenever
again never again when you have that
never again moment that's her again will
American Express call my house and was
such a wrong number cuz I'm not doing
business with never again no matter what
I will never be in a position without
cash from my emergency fund no matter
what no one's gonna come and collect my
car out of the driveway unless it's
because I called them and
broken you know no one no matter what
right and that's what happened to me
because I was stupid and I got myself
into a mess and some of y'all huh
we Chris and I are not you know no one
at Ramsey's gonna get up in your face
and say I told you so enough
thump our chest about how smart we are
we understand that this is your wake-up
call this is your unique moment in time
and you're gonna look back and go thank
God for the coronavirus it changed my
life
mmm when you look back 10 years from now
if you will Jake this moment in time to
change you will look at this and say
thank God
like I say thank God I went bankrupt in
my 20s you knows it changed my life
because I was stupid and I got my
wake-up call thank God for it so if
you're out there you're in if you're if
you're out there you wouldn't you're not
out there you won't be listening to this
but since you're out there you're in one
of two or three camps I suspect most
people have some level of fear if we
want to downgrade it all the way into
concern I have concerns I don't have a
lot of fears but I have some concerns
right now and some of you have fears and
concerns about coronavirus and you're
you're worried about your health you're
worried about the health of the nation
if you have a medical issue that you're
recovering from a member of your family
that is or you're elderly and
susceptible in the high-risk group that
is a valid concern now just like the flu
is a valid concern for you it could take
you out and so the virus could be fatal
in that situation we all know that now
we've all talked about that and we all
know that the vast majority of the
deaths almost all of them have been in
those categories and so almost all of
the folks that were healthy previous to
getting the virus have had full
recoveries so we know that now and so
there's are some facts but people are
pretty freaked out about the virus and
the pandemic and the World Health
Organization has now footing in
psychology that never had before it has
the CDC has footing and credibility in
our minds that it never had before
superseding that of governments even in
some of your minds and people have gone
a little crazy some of you are afraid
more afraid now of the Cure this
everyone stays at home and does nothing
so the economy completely implodes 4 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 weeks
how many weeks of that can this economic
system that we've built endure
how many weeks of that can your family
endure how many weeks of that can your
small business endure and so you're
afraid so
let me first just tell you as Uncle Dave
or Papa Dave or whatever you want to
call it I'm gonna be a little parental
I'm often that so if you're not used to
that get over it when people are afraid
some of you are misbehaving you're being
mean to other people and you need to
stop that you're being mean to other
family members inside your family
because your fear is out of control and
you need to calm your butt down and
behave some of you are misbehaving a
friend of mine was in Walgreens and
stepped across some blue mythical line
in there that has something to do with
social distancing and some twerp and
skinny jeans yelled at her stop that
you're misbehaving your fear is causing
you to misbehave calm down
my friends on Maxwell often says that
hurting people hurt people
and so you're scared and now your fear
you're doing harm to other people and
you need to stop it you need to be kind
the number of mean nasty threatening
horrible things that have been said
about me in the past seven days is off
the scale well I can handle it but it
just reveals
you it doesn't reveal me my character
didn't change a week ago my character
has always been exactly what my
character is I've never been greedy
capitalistic horrible put people in
harm's way for a dollar I've never done
that in 30 years and there's no evidence
to that fact and yet I've been accused
of all of those things because some of
you were just meaner than crud because
you're scared I was growing up I had a
little dog that was a Boston Terrier I
love those little Bulldogs named Mugsy
when I was a little guy I was about
seven years old Mugsy got ran in front
of a golf ball as my neighbor was
swinging practicing driving in the
backyard hit Mugsy in the head knocked
her out when she came back around she
was in shock and he brought her up and
put her in the front yard and the dog
was trying to bite everything because it
was in shock
well I and my naivete thought I could
just run over and little Mugsy who slept
in my bed every night and little Davey
would be best buddies and that dog was
getting ready tearing my arm off and my
dad or one of the neighborhood men
grabbed me and pulled me back before and
they threw a dog through a blanket over
that dog and took it to the vet and it
never again liked golf balls after it
came back around but that's when I first
learned that even things that you love
when they're afraid and wounded will
hurt you you need to stop being one of
those everybody start being little nicer
find someone you can leave an extra big
tip with find someone you can just smile
at they're afraid some of them and
they're more afraid some of them than
they've ever been in their adult lives
because they've never really faced a
crisis before some of these youngsters
have never faced a real hard time for
them the hard time was that the battery
on their cell phone was running low and
they need your mercy in your love and
you need to be kind I don't care what
you do to me I'm gonna be kind to you
I'm gonna love every one of you I'm
gonna give you a big ol hug and I'm
gonna help you and I'm gonna block you
on Twitter if you're a [ __ ]
so this
we're gonna do for the next couple hours
John you ready I loved every second of
it yeah so we'll take some calls those
of you that have questions about fear
and anxiety but I think some kindness is
in order I think some people need to top
order top of the line everywhere just be
kind yeah just stop stop to be kind it's
not it's not our nature to do that when
we're in trouble that's right our nature
is to lash out that's right and some of
these people are showing that they have
the emotional maturity of a four year
old and they're functioning at that
level and the things you say on Twitter
the things you say on Instagram the
things you say to your own family you
ought to be ashamed of yourself
hmm I'd be ashamed of yourself he'd be
nice start right now
be kind spread kindness everywhere
everywhere I'm hugs I don't listen you
want social distancing bear stay away
from me because I'm gonna hug you John
dr. John dallona joins me on air today
newly minted Ramsey personality
answering your questions
Abe is next Ava's in Illinois hi Abe how
can we help hey Dave jr. absolutely ken
hey how's it going yeah hey how are you
helps Danny
I do I just wanted to say you opened my
eyes at such a young age I'm only 16 I
used to spend money like crazy but you
know not just safe does you spend your
money too you know the first people you
don't like is as you say stupid but um
but my uh coke my question is so my
parents owned a small a small business
and like they're freaking out because
all they watch is like CNN and like
they're freaking out about the corner
virus and I wanted to know if you could
help me help them man I wish I was this
wise when I was 16 Dave a beer you were
making me feel better about future
generation man way to go thank you so
much here's what I'm gonna tell you I
would be real direct with your folks and
in a kind and respectful way but I would
say hey ask them to connect with you
that could be hey I would like to go for
a walk
please turn the TV off tell some crazy
guy named dr. D on the radio and Dave
Ramsey show said hey let's just turn the
TV off right now and let's go for a walk
my son he's 9 he challenged me to a
dominoes interaction a few months ago
and now it has gotten to quite the fever
pitch in our house that we talk some
trash and play dominoes together but
just just little ways to connect and
also a but I would tell you is something
I didn't get when I was 16 is the fear
the the worry your parents have that's
real like they love each other they love
you they want to make sure they are
providing for you and so great I'd cut
them some Grayson's like to but is
respectfully and kindly as you can I
would I would recommend that you ask
them to turn the TV off and connect with
you directly you know distract them
right yeah yeah or just start smashing
the windows out maybe they'll I'm just
kidding don't do that he'll become a
different crisis that's right yeah you
can tell them about the drug problem you
have distraction into the mix thing that
happens and it's very difficult for
parents of almost any age to take advice
from their kids
it won't happen probably until you're 60
in their 80 but until then they're
probably really not looking for you to
help them and so you're not in a
position of you're not in a seat that
that that allows you to speak much it's
not not that not telling you have to
stuff your feelings that's not my point
my point is is that moms and dads don't
really care about your opinion right now
you know the but as you haven't been
there yet and that kind of stuff even
though I don't doubt that your opinions
actually on pace here so a couple things
you can do and I just do this about a
lot of things where I have someone I
need to talk to this not gonna listen to
me is I try to think of who else that
could talk to them their pastor their
pastor mom dad pastor and they talk to
have you talked to Uncle Joe who's
really good at business how's he feeling
have you talked to whoever and then the
second thing I do is I I pray for him
and then the third thing is I try to put
new information in front of them that is
hey I just read this article that what
you think of this and it's sure you know
like I posted the good news they
today on Instagram and it's like 300,000
likes in 20 minutes it was bizarre there
was a list of all the good news things
happening around the whole subject of
coronavirus and giving us hope that it's
not forever and it's not gonna last
forever you know just say hey I saw this
post what look at this and let's try to
get some good inputs in front of their
brains not just bad inputs but for you
to sit down and give them wise counsel
at 16 years old might be a little
laughable so I really I probably
wouldn't try that angle we call it the
powdered butt syndrome once someone has
powdered your butt they don't want your
opinion on money and sex so that's how
it goes but Abe I'll tell you this I had
a situation last year where my son came
in and said dad do you love the Astros
as much as me this is pre cheaters and I
was watching the Astros every night and
he just asked do you love them as much
as me in that one question I turned the
TV off and I connected with him and so
you love soo-eun and as much room
there's no potty love nobody loves that
that's right that's right find ways to
connect interrupt interrupt interrupt
some of you were really scared right now
aren't you
to understand I've been there I've been
there where things were so out of my
control
that I couldn't and didn't know what to
do and I couldn't breathe and it's funny
it doesn't matter how many years go by
and it was about was 1988 when we filed
bankruptcy so 40 years ago almost you
know 30 years ago over 30 but uh done -
decades right I mean I still feel it I
still remember that feeling in your
throat that feeling when your stomach is
trying to come up through your throat
that feeling of pounding in the back of
your head from stress and just the fear
I didn't have any money I couldn't get
any money and my lights got cut off and
my water got cut off and I got babies
and some of you are facing that right
now right now
let me tell you if you were not afraid
in the middle of something like that you
would be a psychopath so it does mean
you have mental health if you're afraid
when times are scary that would be a
normal thing to be afraid about things
that are not happening but just might
happen now that's known as a worrywart
right and Dale Carnegie used to say
wrote a book on worry and he sustained a
percent of the things we worry about
never occur I don't know if you can
actually statistically cover that but I
think life will tell you that's pretty
close I don't know if I can confirm that
you know with actual research but he was
making more of a metaphorical statement
but I completely agree
80% of stuff I have worried about in my
life never happened because there saw
some about all of us we we all
anticipate worst-case scenarios and very
few people anticipate best-case
scenarios and live with that very few
people do that now you need to be able
to do both because you need to be able
to look and see when you know
something's turning down and you prefer
prayer for it and you you're smart about
it and all that kind of stuff but I mean
we've got some small businesses right
now that everyone's all jumping up and
down and clapping and so happy that they
were so patriotic and so forward
thinking that they closed down for the
coronavirus the problem is they'll never
reopen they're gone and the families
that worked there lost their jobs now
some of you that are freaking out
coronavirus freakazoids you are so happy
that they're not operating but the
families aren't happy they're gone that
family has lost their job and that that
restaurant is never going to reopen
because there won't be money and they've
gone broke because they were forced to
close and not have customers and they're
gone they're gone well day that's just
weather there's a big keg in have the
virus spreading I don't want the virus
to spread either I'm just telling you
the realities are that those servers and
those chefs and those dishwashers they
don't have a job anymore those people
that worked in that hotel hotels
kaun it's not going to reopen in some
cases now some of them will reopen some
of the big ones are reopened some of the
some of the restaurants have your good
shape they'll reopen but some of these
cities I mean when you take the pictures
I saw in New York City this morning that
it looked like the zombie apocalypse
there's not a soul on the street I've
never seen that in my life and I'm 60
years old in New York City and let me
just tell you that's a lot of businesses
that are never gonna come back that's a
lot of them because those empty streets
mean there is zero revenue and they are
gone and so there's a there's another
there is a thing to be terrified of and
it's unemployment the thing to be
terrified of your family has no income
that's not that's a thing to be
terrified of and you know some of you
that have gone completely berserk have
not considered that in your hysteria
while you were shopping in a grocery
store who did was open and who did have
people there you're just not using good
critical thinking skills so though I
want the voters to spread a rim she's
irresponsible oh shut up that's just
stupid
kind of asinine person would actually
want a virus to spread or be
irresponsible intentionally causing harm
to people that's just dumb of course we
don't want that that's ridiculous but
what we do want and I love small
business small business is the backbone
of America and a whole bunch of them are
gone and next week a whole bunch more of
them will be gone if we don't get them
back open again and the families that
used to work there are on the street
unemployed and if that's you here's what
you do if it all possible do not cash
out your retirement if at all possible
pick up a job delivering food because
nobody's open you know get with get with
uber and deliver things and you can get
you can get some income coming in gets
income coming in and then you take care
of food first at your house this is your
budget priorities shelter second I'm
sorry beautilities second keep the
lights and water on make sure there's
food on your table then the next thing
you do is you take care of shelter you
keep your house payment or your rent
current and then transportation food
shelter transportation and utilities
these are your the four walls of your
house if you keep that going you keep
enough of that going until you get
re-employed back into your career field
just by keeping the wolf away from your
door you've done a great job and you've
turned the corner in a personal
financial crisis caused by hysteria and
you'll make the turn and I've been there
and I've walked lots of families through
that while they might not have had a
whole nation around them at the same
time doing the same thing but I've
walked lots of families through who were
down to the last nub and we go Warwick
what can we do to create income what can
we do to create income what can we do to
create income let's get some income
coming in gets you a leafblower rich
people are afraid of leaves let's go
baby I mean let's go let's get you a
pressure washer everybody's got mildew
somewhere it right I mean let's get
things going here what can we do
can we babysit can we dog walk what can
we do I don't care I'm not too proud to
do anything I'll shovel something let's
go I'm a I just got to make a little bit
of money and keep some food on my baby's
table and then once I do that I could
keep the blights on in my baby's room
that's all I got to do and that's you
get your head around that and you get
back out there instead of sitting around
terrified in the corner sucking your
thumb in a fetal position you get back
out there and you start kicking doors
again and it's hard because you're
scared and you're overwhelmed but in the
middle of that use all of that fear as
energy to go make some money and create
an income as fast as you can as ridicul
if it says believe me there's lots of
people delivering food pizzas and people
right now
lots of them
and some of these industries have gone
up really up there their busiest crud
right now so go get in that go make you
some money and keep the wolf away from
the door meaning you're gonna get the
four walls taken care of and then you
can come back to the baby steps and
stuff later and I'll help you but that's
how you do survival mode